I'm here with with a friend and a mentor
and a living legend give me one more
good adjective for you who are you
talking about
I'm talking about this guy right across
me we're pretty much dressed the same I
feel good about this so I want to talk
about what everyone's talking about
right now which is race in America so
obviously there was this shooting in
Charleston
I just heard just on the way here now
that Lindsey Graham and Tim Scott both
senators from South Carolina are calling
for the Confederate flag to be taken
down
no they woke up they finally woke up I
saw your tweet about it I mean they
finally find that Confederate flag is
treason yeah it is it is a sign of an
era that is the worst mark in the
history of this country slavery is the
black mark no pun intended on the
American landscape and the because what
would you say the people that say well
this is southern pride this is sorry but
it's our hair I would say it's baloney
yeah your southern pride your heritage
is slavery you like that heritage right
that's the good old days the good old
days was depression and no that wasn't
the good old days it was the bad old
days yeah and when you put that up your
black citizens and they vote in your
state South Carolina might have more
black voters than white voters and you
do that as the symbol that's and now
these two senators are saying well we
ought to take it down come on yeah they
knew it was wrong 40 years ago yeah and
isn't an interesting piece with Tim
Scott particularly who's an
african-american senator Republican from
the south I believe the only one that he
took him even this long so that just
shows you how this stuff is so ingrained
right black Republican senators I I've
interviewed many of black congressmen
enough Republican blanks who are
Republican amaze me they come to their
rationale like gay Republican yeah how
they come to their rationale when they
see how the main party votes yeah well
to me with with the gays it always seems
to me it seems so sad that if you were a
gay person that you would have to vote
Democratic because you feel that you
have to vote on this one issue which
marriage should be such a small piece of
what you would actually it's surely but
where the clintons dip into the gut
feeling is all the Tip O'Neill said all
politics is local and when something
hits your gut if you if you're a black
American you could say which party and
stood up more for me yeah the blacks
always were Republicans until the party
turned against them and the Democrat you
know the Democrats to the south right
Southern Strategy and all that kind of
thing we're terrible yeah so what do you
make of the the state of race in America
and I'm so you've interviewed everybody
for as long as we've had a black
president do you think did you think you
think room where we what we've come a
long way yeah in fact the you can
disagree with Obama I've disagreed with
him yet but the tender temper of the
disagreement is particularly distressful
it's racist a lot of it is groomed in
racism yeah
when Mitch McConnell said we were out to
beat him the first day he took office
that's a terrible thing to say as an
American right it was a terrible thing
to say why would you say that right it's
bad for the nation regardless Rush
Limbaugh I hope he fails that's a good
American I hope you fail yeah made a
country fall down ok good for ratings
what I've served it to you that is
that's absurd
yeah so removing Obama from the equation
where do you think the general state of
racism is because it seems it seems that
a lot of people think it's worse than
ever
I don't think it's as systemic as ever
but we have major well in some senses
it's great I mean we made all tremendous
advances I mean blacks in position of
power blacks should keep blacks in
Macbeth I mean that ahead of the Hayden
Planetarium is black the one of the
richest Americans is black clearly the
strides have been great they're
four-star generals you know come on you
gotta admit we elected a black president
yeah yeah but then on the other hand
that's still that insidious part that
still it's a minority but it's a
dangerous minority that would go shoot
up a church yeah so speaking of those
guys what do you make so now everybody
there seems to be this big debate was
this a hate
or a terrorist attack and a lot of
people are saying well if if a Muslim
had done this of course we all would
have said this was a terrorist sect but
because this is a white guy we're not
saying a terrorist attack it seems
obvious to me this is a hate crime and
an act of terror he was trying to
terrorize these people well I don't I
call it hate crime terrorist attacks to
me is when a nation or a body of people
attack civilians when civilians bear the
brunt of it right so after this so as a
lone wolf if I if I do a suicide thing
and go into the neighborhood and blow up
people who aren't in the military if
you're fighting the military and it's a
war that's not terrorism so this is both
terrorism it is a terrorism of sorts but
it's first a hate crime yeah I hates
black city went and shot him yeah so
where do we go from here for the for the
national discussion
well first we should be discussing this
we should be educating more people
should be discuss it's not on the second
tier it should be on one of it should be
a top tier it should be discussed a lot
mm-hmm
it should be discussed a lot in the
places where it should be discussed at
tea party meetings and at meetings in
the south it should be discussed Sunday
mornings at 11 o'clock yeah and which we
know it will be for a couple of weeks
and then it sort of disappears and
unfortunately with the with the crop of
candidates we have coming in 2016
actually Ben Carson is the only African
American on either side so it's probably
not going to be brought up that much
yeah well it should be brought I should
be that's just because you're you're
white be very couldn't discuss it yeah
no I know it of course white person did
the crime